We've been following the investigation that
the FBI and local law enforcement and other
agencies have been doing into the riotous
insurrectionists from January 6th and over
the weekend and over the last couple of days,
more and more people have been getting arrested
and booked.
And we've seen the mug shots and we've seen
all of it.
But one of the questions has been, are they
going to throw the book at these folks?
What are the charges going to be?
Is jail time prison time likely?
And we got a little bit of insight into that
yesterday at a joint press conference involving
the Justice Department and the FBI, where
the latest data is that one hundred and seventy
cases have been opened and many folks are
going to be facing some pretty serious charges.
Of the 170 people found so far, 70 have been
charged.
And that's expected to grow into the hundreds.
Notably, there are many who will be facing
charges of sedition, which carries up to 20
years in prison.
Here is video from the press conference.
Take a listen.
We're looking at significant felony cases
tied to sedition and conspiracy.
Just yesterday, our office organized a strike
force of very senior national security prosecutors
and public corruption prosecutors.
They're only marching orders from are to build.
Seditious and conspiracy charges relate to
the most heinous acts that occurred in the
capital, and these are significant charges
that have felonies with prison terms of up
to 20 years.
In addition to that, we're looking and taking
a priority with cases in which weapons were
involved and cases in which destructive devices
were involved.
As people know, through news reports, there
were pipe bombs found outside the capital.
The ATF is working on that.
Metro police is working on that.
FBI is working on that to find that individual
or individuals who planted those devices.
So in addition to just those cases we're looking
at, we're going to focus on the most significant
charges as a deterrent, because regardless
of if it was just a trespass in the capital
or if someone planted a pipe bomb, you will
be charged and you will be found.
So there's much to discuss here.
First of all, just because they are seeking
certain charges or even filing certain charges
initially tells us very little about how much
prison time, if any, these individuals are
going to do.
And we're going to talk through that.
Now, in the background of all of this is another
issue, which is that the question of murder
charges also needs to be considered for those
involved in the deaths that took place.
But we'll get to that sort of when when we
come to it.
I do think it's important that we temper our
expectations.
And I'll give you an example of that.
And I got a few emails from lawyers about
this.
My instinct was this and then a few lawyers
in the audience emailed me about it.
Sedition is a very high bar to meet in a court
of law and arguably for good reason, because
it's an extremely serious charge.
It's essentially a crime against your country
in a way.
And so I doubt we will see many sedition convictions,
if any.
The legal definition of sedition is is precise
and we'll look at it.
But my expectation is we're going to see people
go down for lesser charges, likely still federal
charges, many with some prison time associated
as well.
But sedition is the act of inciting revolt
or violence against the lawful authority with
the this is the key part with the goal of
destroying or overthrowing it.
This is very much like perjury.
And we've talked before about how, colloquially
speaking, perjury takes place all the time
during trials.
People get up there and they say things that
aren't true.
And and to some degree, they know that they're
not true.
But proving perjury because you need to prove
intent to deceive is difficult.
And it doesn't happen very often.
Many I don't know about.
Most it's very common that in a murder case,
you have witnesses who say opposite things
and to some degree they know that they are
unlikely to be telling what they know to be
the full truth.
But you don't see perjury charges.
You don't, because it's very difficult to
prove and a lot of work for prosecutors much,
much like with sedition, because the goal
of destroying or overthrowing the authority
is part of the definition of sedition.
A good lawyer.
And some of these people are going to have
good lawyers.
Many will not, but some will.
A good lawyer is going to be able to defeat
or at least introduce significant doubt about
the intent of the actions.
They will say maybe, listen, they're on camera
breaking the window or doing this or doing
this in Nancy Pelosi's office or whatever
the thing is.
But disturbing the peace, trespassing, you
know, whatever.
But to show intent to overthrow is going to
be really tough.
Now, some of these people were dumb enough
to post their intentions on social media.
And in those cases, it will be more difficult
to overcome.
But the point is, you know, life is weird
in that way and there are good reasons for
it in many cases.
But I think we should just be be realistic
about what what our expectations should be.
The other the other thing that sometimes will
happen is that events where things are done
as a group, you might much more easily be
able to say as a group, this was seditious
as a group.
What this was, was the attempted overthrow
of an authority.
But that doesn't necessarily mean you can
apply that exact same intent, an agency to
the individual person in a court of law.
And to be clear, I'm talking only what we
are expecting to happen in a court of law.
So the point is, let's wait and see.
But the good news so far is that the number
of people charged is soon to get into the
hundred over one hundred, and it really should
go significantly higher.